you know we were
four months pregnant five months
pregnant always wanted to be a dad knew
that I was about to achieve that that
goal and and take on the biggest and
best project of my life with my my
partner my best friend and
um
I was diagnosed with an eating disorder
that I did not know that I had
um I just knew that I had reflux and
like all of these things that were
making it difficult for me to eat and
didn't realize that there were all of
these traumas from my childhood that I
needed to work through in therapy is
really it's insane so there in my last
couple of months of my contract were
very very difficult physical times for
me this is something that no like I lost
30 pounds at The Knack if I actually
never talked about this uh out loud on a
platform like this at all and man I'm so
glad that I made it through that desert
because here we are now talking to you I
am so much stronger
thank God for that